the opening scene features the mountains
in the Mongolian border where strange
things have been found over the years
these findings include massive fossils
of unidentified creatures as well as
thousand-year-old bodies with their
flesh still intact the scene then cuts
to the year 1979 when a scientist
Professor Yang Chalin assembles a
special team to investigate Kun Lon
mountains he wants to unearth more
information about those mysterious
discoveries we are then introduced to
huayi who is one of the many soldiers
working hard in this excavation their
job appears very tough evidenced by the
fact that they often collapse to the
ground due to extreme exhaustion
thankfully there's the professor's
daughter Yang ping a medic who supports
the people in need according to huai's
narration he has a secret affection
towards ping and he feels like he has
known her for a long time after days of
laborious work the team uncovers a giant
skull leaving everyone astounded moments
later the cave starts shaking and
eventually this leads to a huge
explosion obliterating the entire Camp
sensing danger the armed soldiers under
Commander hanju positioned themselves
outside the cave ready for confrontation
however the only ones to come out are
Professor Yang and some surviving
workers the explosion appears to have
opened a passage inside the cave so Han
asks if anyone wants to investigate it
with the professor since there's a huge
risk of Life most of the soldiers
hesitate to participate however a brave
ping immediately volunteers to help her
father in this Mission this prompts
hubay to follow suit and his best friend
Kang son also decides to tag along in
the end a group of soldiers is
eventually formed to go for this Mission
following this the team sets off for
their mission making their way through
the demolished cave soon they come
across a vast Chasm which they proceed
to climb down until they eventually make
it to an icy platform with a passage
leading to a dark underground upon
climing down even further they find an
unexplored cave filled to the brim with
peculiar fossils is that that Joe Biden
after wandering around for a while they
discover an exit that leads them to the
other side of the mountain Professor
Yang tells huay that according to the
Legends there's the Gate of an ancient
Kingdom in this vicinity belonging to a
pent secret government their
conversation is suddenly interrupted
when the other soldiers find a shocking
Discovery a colossal paw print in the
snow following this the team starts
pursuing these paw prints unaware of the
fact that a giant Beast is nearby on the
way they find numerous butterfly like
creatures fluttering around them upon a
closer look they realize these aren't
butterflies but peculiar looking bats
unbeknownst of the threat they pose one
soldier captures one with his bare hands
triggering an unexpected outcome he
burns down with a blue flame resulting
in his demise two more soldiers rush to
his Aid only to suffer the same fate
seconds later hundreds of these bats
surround the team prompting them to open
fire the noise of the commotion startles
the giant Beast nearby causing it to
retreat however its sudden movement
triggers an avalanche posing another
challenge for the group in a desperate
bid for survival the soldiers begin
running away yet several of them are
killed at one point they're forced to
stop because there is an abyss in front
of them left with no other choice the
soldiers pair up with ropes before
jumping into it as they fall a rope
tying hubay and ping gets stuck on a
piece of ice leaving the two hanging not
long after the Rope snaps causing them
to plunge into the darkness Below in the
next scene H by regains Consciousness
and finds himself in Ping's arms he is
unable to understand how he managed to
survive such a fall this incident
reduces the number of survivors to four
hubay ping Professor Yang and Kang son
the rest didn't have names so we didn't
care about them anyway these survivors
then gather as many supplies as possible
before resuming their excavation
eventually they come across an expansive
cave with a tall tower at its Center the
professor recognizes this place as the
sacred Palace of Kun loon the tower is
said to have nine levels where demon
creatures have been trapped Professor
Yang then kneels down and lights up a
candle the fire instantly creates a
flame that summons a swarm of bats
encircling the tower after this he sends
hubai and ping to the tower's entrance
disregarding Kang Sun's warning as soon
as the duo step in holding hands an
opening appears on the top emitting a
bright light soon after the cave begins
to fill with numerous Spirits assuming
that they have opened the gates of the
devil Kang's son immediately extends
ises the candle thwarting the entire
process unfortunately as a consequence
the cave begins to collapse and the bats
return to attack them sensing the
impending danger Kang Sun sacrifices
himself to divert the bat's attention
enabling the remaining group members to
flee the three of them somehow manag to
find an exit but it's on the high Edge
behind a waterfall while contemplating
their next move the bats catch up to
them and launch their attack H attempts
to fend them off with fire but a bat
strikes him from behind upon witnessing
the emerging Flame ping hastily pushes
him into the water before jumping off
with her father hubay manages to find
her underwater but they're soon
separated by a giant water creature that
takes her away in the aftermath a
heartbroken hubai swims out and makes
his way back to the base once there he
gets his wounds treated while Han
informs him that he's the only Survivor
the commander further mentions that they
found all the dead bodies of their
soldiers except for pings and her
fathers devastated by the loss of his
loved ones hubay decides to quit
everything and Boards a train to return
home without notifying anyone at the
station he is received by his new
employer Mr Wang who assigns him a job
as a librarian from that point forward
he starts working there and lives a
peaceful life one day during a lunch
outing at a local bar hubai unexpectedly
reunites with his childhood friend Kai
Schwan who works as an Entertainer the
following day at work he stumbles upon a
book authored by Professor Yang upon
going through it he discovers several
contents of the same demon Tower which
makes him realize that that the
professor was aware of it since the very
beginning as he connects the missing
dots he understands that only he and
ping could activate the demon Tower
explaining why Professor Yang sent them
in earlier meanwhile Commander Han and
his team discover a coffin containing a
living woman resembling ping they refer
to her as surely this woman possesses an
uncontrollable mysterious power so the
officers are forced to confine her in a
closely monitored room 3 years later
hans's team finds Professor Yang and
brings him to their head quarters
simultaneously in West China Oil City
comes under attack by the enigmatic
giant beasts causing widespread
destruction when Professor Yang learns
of this he theorizes that the tower's
activation has opened gateways in space
and time allowing demonic creatures to
infiltrate Earth in order to seek deeper
insights the professor sneaks out of the
military headquarters the emergence of
these demons appears to have its effect
on huayi as well as the scar in his back
becomes Troublesome one day while
reading in the library his back suddenly
ignites with blue flames and he begins
exhibiting inexplicable Powers he can
now make furniture as well as his friend
float in the air shortly after Mr Wang
shows up and despite witnessing the
ongoing commotion he looks very calm he
quickly gains control over the situation
bringing things back to normaly upon
inquiring what's going on Mr Wang
explains that huai's blood is
contaminated by demonic force due to the
earlier bat attack according to him
hubay now exhibits immense power but its
use can lead him to Hell hubai wonders
how he knows all of this and the latter
uses his own psychic powers to transform
the library into an old tomb he finally
reveals himself to be a protector of
Prince Y from the suin nation he goes on
to explain that Prince Y was hub's
predecessor and he had been the one to
lead mankind against the demon race that
had taken over Earth Prince Y used his
own body to seal the tower trapping most
demons inside but some of them assumed
human form these demons are now looking
for huai because he's the only one
capable of opening the tower back at the
military headquarters Shirley appears to
have recovered her memories and
surprisingly expresses her desire to
meet huayi as a result Han traces him
and pays him a visit at the library the
latter initially refuses to join the
military force again but he changes his
mind after learning about the woman
resembling ping following this hubay
accompanies the commander and kaiwan
tags along Han leads them to Northern
China where he introduces them to the
team that'll be going on a mission to
find the professor the group comprises a
guy named changdong a young woman we way
Shirley and other soldiers overwhelmed
with emotion upon seeing Shirley hubay
addresses her as ping but she insists on
calling herself Shirley the group then
prepares weapons and supplies before
setting off on their mission they make
their way through the desert riding on
camels at one point of their Journey
they're hit by a sandstorm prompting
them to run for their lives as a result
kaai Shuan and three other members get
separated from the group Group after
days of non-stop travel hub's group
arrives at the ruins of Oil City while
khaan's group is still in the middle of
the desert when they're suddenly
ambushed by demonic creatures khaan's
group further splits up in a desperate
attempt to save themselves despite their
efforts the monsters killed two of them
while khaan and another man managed to
reach Oil City reuniting with the main
group upon hearing their confrontation
with the monsters hubai suggests leaving
to avoid the massacre like it happened
earlier in the cave however Chang and sh
decide to stay and complete their
mission their discussion is abruptly
interrupted by the approaching sounds of
monsters as a result they arm themselves
and prepare to fight they soon Gunn down
the first Beast before chasing the
second one however when they turn back
the first one is already gone in the
midst of their struggle Shirley runs
towards an abandoned school and hubai
follows her upon entering he discovers a
bunch of dead bodies hanging from the
ceiling he then comes across a tunnel
leading him to the prince's tomb soon
after he is attacked by a creature
creature which knocks him unconscious
the creature charges to finish him off
but surely intervenes making it go away
in an unexpected turn of events she uses
her powers to put huai's body inside the
coffin meanwhile more demonic monsters
show up at the scene so the group takes
cover in the upper floors of the
building and fights back using silver
bullets and rocket launchers where they
get those it becomes evident that the
demons possess formidable strength
rendering bullets ineffective against
them on the other hand Wei wayi poses as
one of the mannequins and tries her best
to remain Motionless In order to avoid
being caught as soon as the creature
moves away she makes a dash towards Kwan
and the two hide inside a bus
nevertheless the creature locates them
and begins attacking the vehicle after
some time hubai regains Consciousness
and starts screaming for help while he's
at it his arm wound heals at a rapid
Pace leaving him bewildered he is then
teleported into the same cave containing
the Demonic Tower there he Witnesses a
creature dropping Ping's body into a
flame that eventually gets gets
possessed by the demon queen after the
creature departs hubai approaches her
demanding Ping's return however the
queen refuses to give up on Ping's body
because she holds the power to open the
tower she instead proposes that he
accompany her to the Tower and unlock
the long waiting door our hero thinks
for a while but politely turns her down
he insists on being sent back to oil
Town asserting that he'll find some
other way the demon queen finds this
amusing but decides to Grant him a
chance teleporting him back by this time
Sur gains control over all the Monstrous
creatures and directs them to take down
the group members the moment he returns
hubai notices the creature attacking the
bus with khaan and we away so he quickly
takes it down with a rocket launcher
seeing this the other creatures charge
towards him but surely saves him knowing
that he is the key to opening the tower
door she then holds him in her arms and
assures his safety however huai who
realizes that ping will never be back
retrieves a pistol and shoots her three
times times this causes all the
creatures to disappear and the Demonic
Tower to crumble in her final breath she
admits that he is the only one who can
kill her she then unexpectedly kisses
him before collapsing to the ground
moments later Shirley is transformed
into ping who expresses her happiness to
see him one last time however hubai is
still not ready to lose her he carries
her and brings her to the prince's
coffin hoping that it might heal her he
lays down beside her and gently touches
her forehead with his own triggering a
surge of memories from her childhood
turns out ping possessed an inherent
Supernatural ability the power to revive
deceased beings this explains how hubai
survived despite falling into the deep
and dark abyss earlier however Ping's
mother forbade her from using these
powers for some reason one day her
mother passed away after burning in a
blue fire revealing that she was a
descendant from demons who took human
form before the vision ends ping
expresses her unconditional love for
huayi and requests him to find her
father with this she passes away leaving
huai heartbroken after a while of
remorse he regains his composure and
decides to honor her final wish the
movie ends with hubai resuming the
mission with the rest of the team
members subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching